вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми У
фокусі Європа раді що ви приєдналися до
нас за останній рік багато говорили про
Росію та Україну але як щодо країн які
межують з Україною наприклад Молдова
Москву підозрюють у фінансуванні
демонстрації організованих
проросійськими групами в Республіці
Молдова
протестувальники вимагають відставки про
європейської президентки має Санду тому
Багато хто побоюється що їхню країну
спіткає Та ж доля що й Україну
республіка Молдова країна що не має
виходу до моря розташована між ЄС на
заході та Україною на сході знаходиться
сепаратистський район Придністров'я тут
дислоковано понад тисячу російських
солдатів
Олексія його дружина живуть у
безпосередній близькості до
Придністров'я подружжя каже що
побоюється масштабного конфлікту з
Росією
молдовани бояться за своє майбутнє
особливо в районах поблизу кордону з
Україною
понад 60 мігрантів зокрема 12 дітей і
немовля загинули після того як їхні
човен затонув біля берегів південної
Італії вони намагалися дістатися Європи
люди щодня ризикують своїм життям У
пошуках кращого проживання в Європі Якщо
говорити про кількість біженців на душу
населення то жодна країна Євросоюзу не
прийняла стільки біженців скільки
Республіка Кіпр Схоже що ситуація в цій
маленькій острівній державі виходить із
під контролю дорос по лікарку
гуманітарний працівник Він показує нам
табір біженців поблизу столиці нікосій
переповнене місце де люди живуть у
катастрофічних умовах
тут проживає близько тисячі біженців
для правозахисника до роса полікарпу
табір пурнара на півдні Кіпру це скандал
сміття і калюжі - це далеко не все він
сподівається отримати кращу уявлення про
умови проживання
але не встиг він зайти далеко як його
вигнали
охоронець також сказав що зйомка
заборонена
це місце фактично перетворилося на табір
який вийшов з-під контролю
ним неможливо керувати він дорого
обходиться і не служить ті ідеї заради
якої був створений
біженці які прибувають сюди мають бути
зареєстровані перед тим як їх розмістять
у якомусь іншому місці однак місці для
розміщення в інших притулках небагато
тому люди залишаються тут місяцями
спалахи насильства трапляються нерідко у
жовтні 2022 року десятки наметів були
спалені
[музика]
люди тут вони ізольовані вони не можуть
нарешті почати працювати
і думати про свою інтеграцію суспільства
вони просто сидять день за днем їдять і
сплять дуже нездорових умовах особливо
якщо холодно Якщо йде дощ
за межами табору полікарпу розмовляє із
сирійцем який погодився розповісти про
умови проживання у таборі анонімно
діти не їдять тутешню їжу вони до неї не
звикли
туалет і умивальники неймовірно брудні і
жіночі також
Моя дружина ледве наважується туди
заходити
Республіка Кіпр зареєструвала 20 тисяч
заяв про надання притулку у 2022 році це
майже вдвічі більше ніж попереднього
року
офіційно на Кіпрі проживає близько 70
тисяч біженців що дуже багато для такої
маленької країни уряд заявляє що Кіпр не
може впоратися з цією проблемою і
закликає ЄС допомогти
що нам потрібно так це по-перше
обов'язково схема переселення щоб
допомогти країнам що знаходяться на
першій лінії
і по-друге необхідність забезпечити
реалізацію принципу відповідальності
для кіпрського уряду проблему полягає у
північно-східних частинах острова кіпри
які окуповані Туреччиною
саме звідти за словами уряду прибуває
найбільше біженців через лінії
припинення вогню які знаходяться лише
під наглядом ООН ми вирішили поїхати на
північну частину острова
Східну середземноморський університет у
фамагусті один із десятків університетів
що фінансуються в основному за рахунок
іноземних студентів
численні приватні університети важливе
джерело доходу для регіону
але сирійський студент як активіст а
штраф Салім підтверджує що багато з тих
хто реєструється тут не хочуть
залишатися в окупованому Туреччиною
регіоні
можливо їх обманули щодо того Яка це
країна можливо ні але результат завжди
один і той самий вони опиняються з
крутному фінансовому становищі можливо
бездомними можливо просто самотніми у
них виникають проблеми з психічним
здоров'ям тощо і вони вирішують стати
біженцями
рік чим бунга прибув на південь Кіпру
через окуповану Туреччиною піч
зараз він застряг на острові і на
отримання притулку можуть піти роки
у перші дні після пурнари я спав на
вулицю у мене немає дозволу на роботу
але зараз я отримую державну допомогу
розмірі 214 євро цього не вистачає на
життя
Дорош полікарпу каже що у рядки про
намагається відлякати інших біженців
Ми одна з найгірших країн Якщо говорити
про надання прихисту будь-кому
окрім тих випадків Коли у нас немає
іншого вибору
я говорю наприклад про сирійців про
афганців яких зараз прибуває дуже мало
але ми все одно їх приймаємо
повернувшись до пурнару він зустрічає
двох дуже молодих сомалійців за огорожею
табору
один із них Каже що йому 14 років і він
хоче поїхати до Бельгії де живе Його
дядько
вони розповідають йому що тут не
отримують жодної освіти чи будь-якої
іншої опіки
їм нічого робити окрім як сидіти і спати
І так уже півроку
принаймні іде підготовка до покращення
каналізаційної системи Кіпр готується до
більшої кількості біженців
якщо б у вас була можливість оселитися в
одному з цих симпатичних будиночків
далеко від шуму і метушні великих міст
ви б це зробили Що ж незважаючи на свою
іделічну красу ніхто не хоче жити в
цьому іспанському селі пенья-зафра де
абахо мерло сіяні Колос вирішила
врятувати своє село і для цього їй
вдалося зібрати всіх мешканців для
унікальної фотосесії
ці іспанці роздяглися до гола серед них
і фермер що вирощує кабачки куанджо
Перес тут 68-річний чоловік відтворює
позов який він був минулого літа коли
він і більшість його односельців
погодилися зфотографуватися оголеними
Я просто мусив взяти участь мені сказали
що не вистачає людей Оскільки у нас так
мало жителів у мене не було іншого
вибору
опенія завтра деабако проживає лише 16
людей Вони оголили своє тіла щоб
вберегти село від вимирання але тут на
південному сході Іспанії фотографії
оголених людей викликали здивування
тепер Вони прикрашають календар на
травневій світлині зображена Антонія
перея вона хоче показати що люди Тут
більш прогресивні відкриті ніж багато
хто думає
нас просто зображують у поганому світлі
Ми б хотіли щоб нас приймали так як
сприймають людей у більших громадах Ми
так само платимо податки але тут у
нашому маленькому селі ми відчуваємо
себе покинутими
фотографом девіду канту та хуанху
раміресу було не важко переконати
місцевих жителів взяти участь у
фотосесії
[музика]
люди бачать як це роблять їхню Сусіди і
наскільки добре у них виходить так вони
підбадьорюють один одного
ідея створення календаря належить Люсі
Ніколас голові асоціації мешканців у
свої 30 років Вона одна з наймолодших
мешканок пенія-зафра деабаху вона високо
цінує сміливість своїх сусідів
це не лише своєрідне вивільнення Ми
також розвіюємо стереотипи це не
фотографія атлетичних тіл це фотографії
звичайних людей тут люди можуть показати
себе такими якими вони є на відміну від
багатьох відвертих фотографій з якими ми
знайомі я теж дозволила себе
сфотографувати і фотографія вийшла
чудова
[музика]
Люсія та її односельці також
сподіваються що своїми фотографіями вони
надішлють іще одне послання із 1960-х
років у цій місцевості видобувають пісок
і мармур це перетворило колись і
делічний ландшафт навколо села на
кар’єри сповнені шуму пилу і бруду
тут є чимало інших багатств крім цього У
нас є культура яку ми хочемо показати
винний льох сосна яка мабуть старша за
всіх нас разом узятих
Ми просто хочемо Показати що ми дещо
більше ніж те що нас оточує
Педро Санчес також задоволенням позував
для календаря у свої 100 років він став
обличчям грудневої сторінки хоча не
зовсім оголеним
найстаріший мешканець Пенні зафра
деабако З любов'ю згадує дні коли село
було сповнене життям
на вихідних Ми завжди влаштовували
вечірки
одного тижня всі приходили до мене а
наступного до когось іншого
у нас була гітара акордеон і всі
танцювали
Педро Санчес не знає чи зможе фото
проекту оживити село Але він каже що це
було весело
Усі хто мене знає дивується що я
наважився на це
але я готовий робити всіляки подібні
речі
Пенні азафра деабаху та його календар
тепер відомі далеко за межами Іспанії на
радість ферми руху анжопересу який
відкрив у собі невідому раніше Грань у
мене більше немає жодних обмежень Хоча я
ніколи не робив Нічого подібного раніше
я готовий до наступних експериментів
у селі складають плани на наступний рік
ще більше мешканців показують все що
може запропонувати пенья завтра деабаху
[музика]
вирушаємо з Іспанії до Нідерландів
Амстердам приваблює багато туристів
влітку але взимку в місті стає доволі
вітряно і холодно ви можете замерзнути
навіть знаходячись у приміщенні це тому
що більшість будинків старій погано
ізольовані і якщо ви захочете це
виправити доведеться заплатити чималу
Суми проте є добрі самаритяни Які
утеплюють двері та вікна А в деяких
випадках навіть стіни Абсолютно
безкоштовно
бригади сідає на свою вантажні
велосипеди і починає робочий день о 9-й
ранку в Амстердамі
номер один 11 Так ви телефонували
у дощ сніг чи бурю ми збираємо
інструменти і Сідаємо на велосипеди
ми виїжджаємо до клієнтів за будь-якої
погоди адже вони на нас розраховують
[музика]
Френсіс Бригадир і співзасновник фікс
бригади те що починалося як
волонтерський проект тепер стало
оплачуваною роботою
сьогодні їх викликали на ремонт квартири
швидкий огляд показує що роботи Буде
багато
гиря я хотів показати вам це тут уздовж
нижнього краю дверної рами ви можете
чітко бачити синю смугу це означає що
тут є протяг
ось погляньте якщо підтримуєте руку тут
То можна відчути
тут на горі 16 градусів тепла а тут
внизу всього 5 градусів
негроматичні вікна надто часто явище дві
з трьох квартир у Нідерландах поганої
ізольовані тут дверний ущільнювач був
просто приклеєний до Рами зроблено
нашвидкоруч і неохайно
вам не дошкуляє холод що задуває звідси
ми дуже часто вмикаємо опалення
А це вікно що інше як просто отвір у
бетонів
вікна просто вставили без шпаклівки і ми
мусимо все переробляти
квартира Лізи та морізки потребує багато
роботи ущільнювач необхідних дверях
зношений і майже жодна з лампочок не
замінена на енергозберігаючий LED
лампочки я зрозуміла що багато чого тут
не ідеальне але часто я просто не знала
як це змінити і зверталась до
обслуговуючої компанії але вони теж не
дуже допомагали ми дійсно дзвонили їм 4
рази щоб поскаржитися на проблеми хтось
приходив але наприклад про утеплення так
ніхто і не подбав
тепер цим займається фікс бригада але до
них можуть звернутися лише
малозабезпечені люди їхні послуги
безкоштовні
гроші на зарплату працівникам надходять
із грантів ЄС
цей проект надихнув компанії в інших
містах
наші клієнти це люди які отримують
пільги або фінансово-залежні від держави
якимось іншим чином
деякі з них інваліди інші погано
володіють голландською мовою
якщо ви не знаєте мову достатньо добре
щоб повідомити про свої проблеми
управляючі компанії вони просто
відмахнуться від вас
ми чули про такі випадки багато разів
за оцінками близько 750 тисяч голландців
мають проблеми з оплатою рахунків за
електроенергію Багато з них звертаються
до Френсіса і його колег зараз в одному
лише Амстердамі одночасно працюють 6
бригад
нам не вистачає інструментів і
матеріалів замість того щоб замовляти
нові матеріали раз на місяць тепер
доводиться замовляти їх раз на тиждень
але це дуже чітко показує наскільки це
потрібно людям з нашої цільової групи
за словами Френсіса ця цільова група
часто дуже мало довіряє владі а тим
більше таким проектом як фікс бригада
фікс бригада заброньована аж до серпня
їхні успіх надзвичайно завантажує їх
роботою
[музика]
гірські лижі найпопулярніший зимовий вид
спорту в Європі в одній лише Швейцарії
налічується понад 300 гірськолижних
курортів але Вони переживають не
найкращі часи через високі ціни на
енергоносії та Кліматичні зміни Антон
кальберрев ніколи не був фанатом
величезних курортів протягом 10 літ він
керує одним із найменших гірськолижних
комплексів у Швейцарії причини його
популярності в тому що це Сімейний
бізнес коли схили майже повністю у
твоєму розпорядженні тут є відчуття
Свободи яке важко знайти у швейцарських
Альпах у наші дні всього 20 кілометрів
лижних трас два підйомники і жодних
планів на розширення Саме так все
подобається тону кальберру понад
півстоліття він керує невеликим сімейним
гірськолижним курортом Сарн хансенберг у
грі зоні у свої 92 роки він досі сам
катається на лижах
я не майстер катаюсь так само як і 50
років тому
щодня Антон кальберрен насолоджується
приголомшливим краєвидом разом зі своїм
онуком денісом батько Антона придбав
гірськолижний курорти наприкінці
1960-х років усі його 13 дітей
долучилися до справи
усі спустошили свої банківські рахунки і
вклали гроші в крісельні підйомники
у банку було кілька сотень тисяч
швейцарських Франків але допомагали всі
інакше нічого всього б не було
курорті прості траси пагорб для катання
на санчатах це приваблює сюди зокрема
сім'ї багато гостей постійні відвідувачі
тут найкраще тут мало людей можна дати
дітям погасати
він маленький але класний тут не так
багато народу і все дуже знайоме я
сподіваюся що вони зможуть продовжувати
працювати
на висоті 1700 метрів є ресторани
кімнати для гостей
Денніс відповідає за кухню вже три роки
він провів тут більшу частину свого
дитинства
озираючись назад Це була моя мрія
взимку Ми приїжджали сюди майже кожні
вихідні і каталися на лижах
гора досі для нього рідний дім а дідусь
приклад для наслідування
він тут однозначно головний для мене він
той хто завжди пояснить що і до чого
і схоче зберегти місце яке він так любив
у дитинстві навіть якщо через зміни
клімату снігу взимку випадає на багато
менше Він каже що завжди потрібно
придумувати щось нове і бути креативним
Так зараз безумовно не легко цей рік був
надзвичайно важким для багатьох ми не
могли кататися тут на лижах на початку
сезону тож це було проблемою але
принаймні у нас була гірка для санчат ми
подбали про те щоб вона працювала щоб
люди могли нею користуватися
наприкінці
1990-х родина купила крісельний
підйомник за символічний Франк у
більшого гірськолижного курорту якому
він більше був не потрібен але в іншому
тут мало що змінилося
[музика]
коли старший менеджер втомлюється від
усього цього він у самітнюється у
приміщенні яке називає своєю концертною
залою поки великі гірськолижні курорти
намагаються знайти способи впоратися з
кліматичними змінами і стати більш
стійкими Він задоволений своїм підходом
стриманим орієнтованим на сім'ю туризмом
[музика]
ми завжди дбали про ландшафт будували
тільки те що було необхідно
ніяких величезних потворних бетонних
блоків в цілому все так як було 50 років
тому
за винятком снігу його вже не вистачає
втім Антон кальберрев впевнений що його
онук щось вигадає
А як ви любите проводити свої
гірськолижні відпустки поділіться з нами
ми повернемось за тиждень а на сьогодні
це все дякуємо за перегляд і до зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]